so the first thing is in your book what
I'd like you to draw is kind of rather
than I've done a measurement of every
single well not every single but all of
these many angles if you want you can
actually draw a nice kind of small set
of axes here and you can draw just the
actual tops if you connected all of the
dots I'm not going to do it on this
because there are a few things I want to
point out in this first but essentially
what you're getting is this kind of well
you know how this is the sine graph that
we've got here right that shape is
called the sinusoidal wave it's a really
important shape anything in nature that
works in a kind of rhythmic cycle like
for example tides as they go up and down
does this look anything like a wave
right that comes from down a radio
signal you know electromagnetic
radiation right it's just this up down
up down up down up down of energy coming
across that we can measure on the
electromagnetic spectrum does the same
thing the Sun as it goes up and down and
up and down if you took a picture of
where the Sun was at say for example 11
o'clock every day at the same point same
time because of you know winter hours
and all that kind of thing right and
some are and it's changing the position
of the Sun well it's not going to go
down here exactly the position of the
Sun is going to follow this same kind of
pattern because it is a rhythmic cycle
literally every single rhythmic cycle in
nature follows the same kind of pattern
now a few things to observe firstly when
you have a look at these angles
hopefully you have at the very least but
in 90 180 and 270 degrees as well as pi
onto PI and 3 PI 2 radians
where have we ended where's the final
spot over here it's 360 degrees which is
also
zacky's used red that's 2 pi radians
isn't it 2 pi now what you should have
noticed for both your sy graph and your
cosine graph is you have come back
around literally to where you started
did you notice that on the sine graph
you started measuring how tall is that
spot there at 0 its 0 that's how
hi you go and when you end your back to
where you started
safety with cosine your first
measurement for cosine like how far a
cross did I have to go you went all the
way up by the way what is this vertical
scale what's the top this is that it's
one cuz this is the unit circle that's
the furthest you go and all the way down
the bottom here because the lowest that
it gets is negative one right very good
now what did I can do if you haven't
already mark did one and negative one do
so also I'd like you to look for where
1/2 and negative 1/2 are 1/2 and
negative 1/2 so for example I can say
with certainty that'll be 1/2 and
negative 1/2 is a bit harder to say but
I'm gonna put it out there now you know
half of you have the sine graph of 1/2
you have the cosine graph if you have
the cosine graph I want you to have a
look at this one for a second do you
notice how quickly the sine graph climbs
up to 1/2 how quickly it happens I
wonder if you worked out how I board
that so fast it's not that I measured up
to the 1 sine of a particular angle it's
an exact value sign of a particular
angle gives you a half what angle is it
sign of big thing thing have a look it's
on there right sign of 1020 it's 30 sine
30 degrees or side of piled six that's
equal to 1/2 right now something I want
to point out to you is and again this is
what I want to draw extra stuff if I go
all the way across here you can see 30
degrees or pi/6 radians is not the only
time you get sine of that equals 1/2
you've got all over here at a hundred
and fifty degrees or what's that in
radians 150 degrees think think Fig can
we convert it 150 degrees is five of
these right so it should be five PI on
six so there's five PI on six right
there
so if I say that's yeah that's 30
degrees right 30 to 150 is five times
bigger
so pilot six to five point six five
times baby right now you'll also notice
right the sine graph is positive up here
of course it is because on the unit
circle you're measuring up up up up up
all the way from naught to 180 right and
that's why on the quadrants diagram
right see that a and s sine is positive
up here down here you've got T and C
sine is negative down here cuz you're
below the sine is the measurement of how
up-and-down you are on the unit circle
okay you'll also notice we've got some
interesting points here at PI or 2
radians it looks like up here and also 3
pi love to radians even though we
haven't got to there as a topping we
have a name for this kind of point here
where it sort of stops for a second
after going up and then it comes back
down we called these we actually had two
days for these one is a stationary point
but if the graph stops going up for a
minute it stops
that's what stationary means or it stops
going down because it can't go any
further I can't go any lower on the unit
circle but then as well you notice it
changes direction doesn't remember what
that's called wouldn't change this
direction it it turns around so we also
can call this a turning point okay now
have a look at this smooth curvature
tried my very best to do it on here okay
like so now it looks so superficially
like a parabola
it looks superficially like a parabola
if you have a look at this part here
okay but it's really important for you
to understand this is not a parabola the
sine and the cosine guys the
trigonometric functions yeah they go up
and down down and up but they are
actually very very different shapes okay
all right can we switch over whose
cosine did we pick we've already got one
so I'll use it okay let's that's okay
that's fine all right well one the other
way around
I don't there we go there we go sorry
it's because I've moved the the head up
and to the left yeah there we go
all right no I think I'm already zoomed
out as far as I can go I'm just gonna be
about believe it yeah booth just
physically very nice okay
outstanding okay so we have a look at
this guy here right let's let's add on
if you haven't already actually don't
freeze it then you can give back to
thank you didn't have a question
so hold up yes just mostly okay so say
deal we've got PI on to here we've got
three PI on to here and then we've got
PI smack bang in the middle again when
you have a look at the quadrants diagram
right when you have a look at the
quadrants diagram where for example is
cosine negative over here have a look
where is it negative it's it's on the
left hand side right and left hand side
of here in other words what angles from
pi onto all the way to door it goes past
hundred eighty doesn't it goes to 270
which is three pile to which is exactly
this range in here you see that the
graph is below because what you're doing
for cosine you're measuring the
x-coordinate the x-coordinate is to the
left over here they're all negative
negative negative negative negative
that's why these guys are positive okay